they can get away with it.
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? Because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran, gives you reminders. Download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on your Makyama that you read it
wherever you was.
To brothers and sisters and dear
friends, welcome to another video where
we're going to be reacting to Adam Salah
in the park minding his own business
where a dirt bag walks in. And who's a
dirt bag? The synonym for a dirt bag is
a Zionist. He walks in there and let's
talk what he had to say and let's just
think to ourselves if a Muslim was to
say what he said, where would the media
be? What would they be doing? So, we're
going to watch that in guys. Don't
forget to download the Salah Pro app.
Absolutely free. Bra sisters, we have
worked on it for months on end.
Inshallah. Free kibla finder ads free
salah reminders encourages to pray
salah. You can book a guided uh salah
instructor, order a guided prayer mat,
find your local salah hubs, watch videos
on how to pray. It's all there for free.
Inshallah. Let's get straight to the
video.
>> You support Palestine?
>> Yes, I do.
>> Why?
>> I love Palestine, man. Come on.
>> Losers.
>> There's a genocide going. We're going to
win. There's a genocide going on.
>> Genocide is a war. It's not a genocide.
faith. I hope they all
>> Yo. Yeah. You're just showing your true
colors, bro.
>> He said, "You hope what? You hope what?
>> I hope all the Palestinians get
>> what?"
>> He hopes all Palestinians get a bullet
in their head. Imagine if I said, "I
hope every Jewish person gets a bullet
in their head or every Israeli gets a
bullet in his head." Imagine if I made
those words. Imagine I go and confront a
Zionist YouTuber and I say these words.
Forget my
whole life will be flipped upside down.
They can casually casually not only that
you can watch our other video where they
casually bro in a funeral they are
crying about their dirt bag coward IDF
soldier who ran away like a coward in a
in a bulldozer and uh got uh liquidated.
Yeah. He turned into a liquid. Yes. And
they're mourning like he used to come
home and say I'm going to destroy my
Arab houses. Let's carry on. Let's see
what happens with this guy cuz he seems
very brave. I mean you know surely it
doesn't look like it doesn't look like a
coward. Let's carry on.
>> You [__] up, bro. You have no heart.
What do you mean? What do you are you
Zionist?
>> Of course. That ass.
>> I'm a Jew. Look at me. Jew.
The Jewish people who support Palestine,
bro.
>> Exactly. Free Palestine.
>> They tell you dookie energy. You're a
donkey. They'll give you a donkey. Just
call his chat a donkey.
>> He's a wa is a donkey. Wallah is a
donkey. I can see it.
>> Yo, how about this? How about you? How
about this? Since I don't I have boxing
gloves in a car. Let's have a boxing
match.
>> I'm not gonna lie. I love that because
you're gonna come here coming up to my
face like that. Let's have a boxing
match. Legal boxing match. He's got
boxing gloves. is ready. Surely this
Zionist man who's you know they you know
they are very brave he's surely going to
accept this. Yes. Let's see what happens
now in
>> how's it feel being Neon's le
my brother. Neon's my brother.
>> Neon's my brother
to us.
>> Let's get boxing gloves and let's let's
box
>> the stream. Let's get boxing gloves.
Come gym. I'm not going to box you on
this.
>> No. No. We'll box right here. Let's go
to a gym. We'll box.
>> Okay. Good. So he's No, no. Look, you
got to give it to him. You got to give
it to him. He's he's obviously got a
little bit shook. I thought, you know,
he's he's backing out, but I said, "No,
no, no. We can, but let's go to a gym.
Okay. And you're like, "Okay, you know
what? Let's it's going to be all
organized. Let's go." Yeah. Because
these individuals, you know, look, it's
his highness. Who do they target? Men,
children, men, women, children. That's
what they target. And you can see
clearly him saying they all deserve a
bullet in the head. So, you can see
these people are the most vile human
beings. Zionists to walk planet Earth.
Let's see when he says, "Let's go to the
gym." Let's see if he's going to accept
that.
>> No, I'm not going to get
>> box to the grass. No, we can go to a
gym. Why you want to go to a gym?
>> Because it's legal there. I'm not going
to box here. It's legal.
Yo, let's go to the gym, bro.
>> All right. Yo, we going to the gym right
now. Let's go. Let's go,
>> bro. Man's making phone calls. Adam Sus,
you want to go to the gym? We'll go to
the gym. Let's see. It's really Let's
see what the excuse is going to be. Go.
Let's go.
>> What gym you talking about?
>> Which one do you want to go to?
>> You want to go to mine?
>> No. No. He's saying there's one nearby.
There's one in Brooklyn. Which one is
yours?
>> Brooklyn's too far.
>> All right. Which one's yours?
>> All right. We're going to go to his one.
So, we're going to go to his one.
>> All right. We'll give you the address.
We'll give you the address. I got you.
Sus. Well, I'm having a boxing match
right now. Sus.
>> How long are you in the city for? Don't
worry about it, bro.
>> I was drinking. I'm not going to box you
now.
>> I I was drinking. I'm not going to box
you now. First, we'll go to the gym.
It's not legal here. Uh and you can see
from his body language. You can see is
full-blown coward. These Zionists are
the biggest cowards. They attack
children and women. Yeah. Okay. Let's
go. Oh, I'm not going to box. You know,
I've been drinking now. All of a sudden,
he became a drunkard. Yes. Alcoholic,
scumbag. Yeah. Okay. Subhan. And you can
see IDF soldiers in Israel are
committing. I can't say the word.
They're unaling themselves, brothers and
sisters. Yes. Why? because of the
atrocities they have uh done there's so
many there was one IDF soldier yes dirt
bag who set himself on fire he was
nearly setting the whole uh wood uh the
the the he was in the forest on fire
subhan allah this going to happen you
are going out there then coming to you
think you're going to get away with it
you think there's not going to be
consequences in this life let alone in
the hereafter you're going to have
psychological effect you are going to
lose your mind and may Allahh make you
lose your mind more so the excuse is
what he's drunk let's carry on
>> yo get [__] out of here
>> what did I
He agreed to box and now he's pussying
out.
>> I can do it right here.
>> He's scared. He's scared. He's scared.
>> Let's go. Back up your
>> back up your back up your
free.
Ask your chat. Ask your fight.
>> Ask your check.
>> Bro, I would pay anything to see this
guy get knocked out by Adam Salah. Bro,
I would have pay anything. And he knows
what would have happened. He knows what
would have happened. That's why he's
avoiding it. And this is their reality,
guys. This is their reality. They will
not fight like Allah says in the Quran
except in towers, fortified towers. Yes.
And they will come and say we are
peacemakers. You guys are the biggest
elhateen walking this earth. And the
whole entire world has seen the mass
drop off. The entire globe knows and it
is their arrogance. Their arrogance of
thinking they can do whatever and get
away. No one in their right mind will go
and commit a genocide and record it on
HD 4K. But these people think that they
can get away with it. And the entire
globe wall these Zionists have been
kicked out from restaurants in Thailand,
Philippine, Spain, Italy. People have
known their reality and not they
couldn't put every Jewish in that
categist
for that matter in let's carry on. You
came here. I'm going to fight you.
>> I just want to ask you about
what happened. Tell them what you say
about street. You're too lazy to leave.
>> What you say about Valentine
Street,
bro?
>> He's not going to fight for what he
represents. This is a true example of
what you're not supposed to be. If you
like what you represent, that's not what
you're supposed to be.
>> What you represent.
>> Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
>> Take off your tongue. Take off. Give him
some.
>> Come on, let's go.
>> This is hilarious. That's hilarious. He
refused. He froze. He throws the boxing
gloves away. He's a coward.
[Laughter]
>> So, we're doing
a came up to me here. We do. You're
going to sell me to try to kiss me. Like
my man,
>> guys. Just so you know, this is the IDF
soldiers, by the way. This this is an
IDF soldier. Look at him. Look how he's
moving. Yeah. This is your clear IDF
soldier. Yes. Who will fight behind
tanks, etc. And guess what? They still
get liquidated. They are still getting
liquidated. They are getting absolutely
annihilated on all fronts. And this is a
fine example of what a coward Zionist
looks like. And they're all the same.
>> You're gay.
You're gay.
>> Your teeth are yellow. Your teeth are
yellow.
>> Your teeth are yellow, buddy.
>> Let's go, bro.
>> You're gay.
>> Don't pull up on me next time. You [__]
[__] [__] got kiss me.
>> Yo, you're a [__] Next time don't pull
up on me. If you don't want to fight,
get out of here and fight.
I don't knock you out. I'm going to get
a [__] smoke. No smoke.
>> You want no smoke?
>> Wait, can I talk to you? Can I talk to
you?
>> No, no, no. I'm not trying to get
assaulted.
>> Let's go down to Chambers and see it.
>> Yo, get the out.
>> You're not wanted here.
>> You're not wanted here. You're not
wanted out of here. See, you're not
wanted here.
>> Going, buddy.
>> Yo, you hit him.
>> It's on camera. You hidden. I have it on
camera. You hit it. You hit it.
>> You have it. I have it on camera, buddy.
>> Oh, boy. This is I think this is the
most satisfying video I've watched in a
long time. I'll be honest with you.
After seeing that coward Abraham get
liquidated and in their funeral, they
are mourning his, you know, not even
mourning. They're just crying. You know,
he was he was going to kill more
Palestinians and destroy my houses.
Yeah. You know, it's funeral from hell.
You can watch that video on my channel,
a video before this. But this is this is
so satisfying, guys. I I wish I just had
popcorn. Yes. Sweet and salty. Get sold
by
>> Get out of the park.
>> Leave the park. Leave the park.
>> Pull up on me here. Let's do it here.
What do
>> you mean? Get out of here, bro.
>> Leave the park. Leave the park.
>> Why you running?
>> This is what Israelis do. Israelis are
running. Israelis run.
[__]
baby.
[Music]
>> We all
on this.
>> I'm not trying to We're not trying to
We're trying to have you square.
>> And this is exactly Look at the way he's
running. This is exactly what happens in
Gaza, guys. By the way, this is exactly
what happens in Gaza. Yes. When the
armored tankers are not around him, this
is how they run away. Look how he came.
so boldly, so confident, etc. And when
they realize they are cowards and they
only kill men, women, and children, they
run away. But we're going to come to
also a news article written making him
look like the victim. Like it's
anti-semitic. We're going to come to
that in a minute. Let's just watch this,
but it's nearly finished. Look how he's
run away.
>> You're killer.
>> We don't care about you. We're not going
to touch you.
>> I said we can go down
the public with 15 people around me.
Bro,
>> we're not going to touch.
>> That's crazy. Go to a gym with a rat
doing not worth that [__] bro.
Get out of here, bro. Get the [__] out
of here, bro. Get the [__] out of here.
>> Okay, this is crazy. I've just found
out, bro, that this guy himself is
actually a fighter. Israeli fighter
challenges Muslim influencer Muslim
Muslim influencer over Chase the Jew
stunt. Okay, look at this. Look how they
twisted the story. Adam Salah filmed
intimidating Jewish man New York City,
New York City park wearing boxing gloss
and yelling free Palestine. Yes, this
guy is actually a fighter. He's actually
a fighter and he refused. So it goes,
"An Israeli martial artist has
challenged a Muslim YouTuber to a fight
after footage emerged of the influencers
chasing a Jewish man free a New York."
Oh, no, no, no. One second. An Israeli
martial artist has challenged a Okay.
No, the guy in the thing is a coward.
Yes, another dirt bag Israeli martial
artist has challenged Muslim Yucha to a
a fight. Viral video from the weekend
shows lightweight professional boxer
Adam Salai who has 4.7 million followers
sprinting after the man in Washington
Square. He's look look how they twist
the story. Look how they twist a
innocent Jewish man. He was just walking
about his business and the Muslims said
we're going to pick on him. On the
footage, you can clearly see he's the
one that comes and says, "I hope every
Palestinian gets a bullet in the head,
gets away scot-free." Yes. And now some
other dirt bag Zionist is challenging
Adam Salah to a boxing match. That's
what it was. Uh in a post to social
media on Monday, Israeli Israeli net
levy known as Jejitsu. Ask Yeah, he'll
get probably choked out. Yes. Ask Adam
Sal, I see it makes you feel like a big
man to chase Israelis in the park and
harass harass older people at a kosher
restaurant. I tried to talk to you
civily on Instagram, but you played the
victim and then blocked me. Now you're a
boxer. I'm a real fighter. Okay, no
problem. Then find someone. If you're a
boxer, Salah can fight you. If you're an
MMA fighter, he's not MMA fighter. Find
someone. Any Muslim will take you out,
bro. Any Islam, what's his name? Islam
Mak Makv. What's the name? I can't
pronounce his name.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Islam Makv.
>> Yeah. Islam Makv.
>> Yeah. Islam Makv. Go challenge him. You
dirt bag. Yes. You'll get rinsed. Yes.
So, I've got an offer for you. If you
have a problem with Israeli Jews,
Zionists, whatever you want to call it,
you tell me where and when and I'll meet
you there. See you soon. Okay. In August
2023, Levy defeated an internet troll
who supported a Holocaust denia. He also
responded to anti-semitic rants by Kenny
West. So, as you can see, guys, they
have changed the whole narrative. Subhan
Allah. Uh to um Muslims chasing a Jew
when you know very clearly that's not
the case. And the whole world is not
buying your nonsense. Those days are
over. It is the beginning of the end of
Israel. Hope you guys enjoyed the video
as much as I did, brothers and sisters,
and it was satisfying. Alhamdulillah,
the it's like I said before, it is the
beginning of the end of Israel. May
Allah subhana wa ta'ala allow us to live
to see the end where the Palestinians
will live back in their lands where the
Muslims, Jews, and Christians who lived
in harmony together will live again
where you can see now even churches are
being attacked and bombed and Christians
being killed. And you know how the
Christians are being treated in in
Israel being spat at. Brothers and
sisters, till next time.